[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISTIN COPELAND:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Google Cloud Next.
We are super pumped to
have all of you here today.
And even more excited to tell
you a little bit about what
it's like to be a Googler.
Which I'll tell you, going back
a few years, how many of you
have seen the movie
"The Internship"?
Owen Wilson?
Yeah?
That's totally what I pictured
life at Google being like.
And yes, there are some
truths to that movie.
But we're going to
learn a little bit more
about what it's like
to work at Google, what
the week in the life
of a Googler is,
what it's like to be a
software developer and product
manager at Google, and we've got
some incredible panelists who
will be sharing
a little bit more
about the in-depths of what
it's like to be at Google.
To kick things off,
I'll introduce myself.
My name is Kristin Copeland.
I'm Staffing Lead
here at Google.
So part of our people
operations organization.
And we unfortunately are
missing one of our panelists.
She couldn't make it today.
But I will kick it over to our
wonderful, very intelligent
panelists to introduce
themselves, and tell you
just a little bit about their
name, what they currently do
here at Google, and their role.
So Lakshmi, over to you.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Thank
you I'm Lakshmi Sharma.
I'm Director of Product
Management for Networking.
So with my team of
product managers
and working with my
engineering team,
I try to kind of
support the awesomeness
of high performance, low
latency network that lot
of our Google services, most of
our Google services and cloud
services are built upon.
TARA HERNANDEZ: Hey, everybody.
I'm Tara Hernandez.
I'm an Engineering Manager
in Google Cloud division.
My team specifically works on
developer tools and container
images.
So if you do things
with Kubernetes,
you're probably using
our stuff in some way.
But don't complain,
I'm the manager.
JIMMY MKUDE: Hi.
My name is Jimmy.
I work for Google Cloud's
Video Intelligence.
AI, focus on video.
If you use any of
our AI APIs, that's
probably related to my team.
Thank you.
MARISA CHOW: Hi, everyone.
I'm Marisa Chow.
I'm a software engineer
on a team working
on building video conferencing
tools specifically at Google.
Although we partner very
closely with our friends
in Hangouts Meet,
part G Suite, to bring
all the cool technology to you.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Awesome.
OK.
So first things first.
Let's just kind of
hit the baseline here,
and I'd love to hear a
little bit from each of you
about what does the week in the
life of a Googler look like?
Specifically in your role.
So as an engineering manager,
as a software developer,
and as a product manager.
So Tara, why don't you
kick things off for us?
TARA HERNANDEZ: Meetings.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
(LAUGHING) Yes.
TARA HERNANDEZ: Seriously.
In fact, my team
was really excited
because I made them
go to less meetings.
And they were practically
tears of relief.
But with a company
the size of Google,
and with the scope that we
have, just even within the cloud
space, trying to
get coordinated,
make sure that we're moving
towards a common goal
is very challenging.
But it's also pretty
exciting, too.
I'm used to a small company.
My last company
had 224 employees.
Google's a little-- has been
a different experience for me,
to say the least.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I
can absolutely imagine
and can relate.
I'm sure many of
you can, as well.
Jimmy, tell us a little bit
about what a typical week looks
like for you as at Googler.
JIMMY MKUDE: So, we as
a software engineer,
because it's already in the
career, mostly is coding.
I'll say 80% coding.
The rest is just meetings.
But--
TARA HERNANDEZ: We're really
selling it here, aren't we?
[LAUGHTER]
JIMMY MKUDE: But the
meetings do help,
because that's how you would
like to design as a team.
Which is pretty good to get
that team work in meetings,
get the design down.
You come up with an idea,
share with your teammates.
Then after that you
get to implement,
and everyone goes your way, and
we kind of just work together.
So mostly it's coding.
But there's a lot of
teamwork involved in that.
MARISA CHOW: Very similar to
Jimmy, software development
at Google is mostly coding.
I like to tell people that
most of my time is coding,
and the rest of the time,
I'm sitting in meetings
deciding what to code.
So that is my week.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Awesome.
And Lakshmi, I know your
roles a little bit different.
But are you in
meetings all day, too?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So, I
just give an example
of how my first day
here at Google was.
So I joined January last year.
I was in Google training.
I came to meet my
team and my peers.
So I came to the PM area,
and then it was before 5 PM.
And then there was
nobody out there.
And then I was told already,
hey, most of the PMs,
they're always talking to
customers, internal, external.
They must be in
some other building
talking to some kind of
customer or stakeholders.
And I went in and
there was nobody.
So, yeah, meetings, but
it's just that you're always
talking to somebody who is--
that's the kind of life
of a product manager.
You're talking to customers,
and those customers
are [INAUDIBLE] customers.
Like auto engineering
stakeholders,
marketing people, sales people.
So we are always talking
to a lot of people,
learning and then
trying to build products
that our customers
really, really can use.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Tell
us a little bit more
about the relationships
with customers,
how you interact with them.
And sort of just how
that partnership looks.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: I've been
at various big and small
companies, too.
So one thing which I
would say, one advantage
of being at Google, and I will
be honest, it's a blessing,
I would say.
Being Google and
having this company
done so much of amazing
work and infrastructure.
I work in infrastructure team.
It's always that brand and the
performance and the quality
that we have, it is
actually easy to go and talk
to customers.
They want to listen to you.
Primarily because, we are
so much engineering focused.
So the typical day is
like, we work very closely
with engineering team.
Like product management team,
here it is, two in a box.
We work with engineering.
And we have, we say, our
outside in, as well as,
inward focused innovation.
So we talk to
customers all the time.
Since morning, I've been talking
to partners and customers.
We learn from them.
We build for them.
And then we also have
our continuous innovation
coming from billions
of users who
have been using our services.
So it's like a
continuous learning
and continuous innovation.
And we keep giving to each
other throughout the world,
to our customers, as well
as to our own services.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
That's awesome.
What about for the rest of you?
I'd love to hear a little bit
more about on your day to day.
Talk to me about how you're
working with open source,
or how you're working
with internal consumers,
or projects that are maybe
related but upstream.
Go ahead.
Take it off, Tara.
TARA HERNANDEZ: All right.
I'll go.
So I've done engineering
infrastructure
for 25-something years.
I was involved in open source
as far back as Mozilla.
So it's something that's
super important to me.
And being able to work
at a company like Google
where all the things
that my team works on
are all open source
based is pretty awesome.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
Marisa, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about what is
your favorite thing about
being a developer at Google?
MARISA CHOW: It's
a vivid cliche.
There are a lot
of things I really
enjoy about being a developer.
And I mean, right off
the bat, my teammates
that I have are just
really incredible.
I came to Google basically
fresh out of college.
And so I was moving
from an environment
where coding was
very theoretical.
The problems that we had were
all theoretical in nature.
OK, so this is
what it might look
like to deal with
concurrency problems.
But then when you
come to Google,
you are suddenly thrown into
this environment where you're
not only forced to see how the
theoretical principles play out
in practice, but also,
you're challenged
by so many different factors
that you don't really
think about when you're in
the vacuum of university.
So for example, out
video conferencing fleet
is all throughout the world.
So we deal with
a lot of problems
around, for example,
time zone issues,
or problems of
different hardware
available in
different countries.
All of the problems
of scale, as well.
For example, if 1% of our
videoconferencing fleet
goes down, that's hundreds of
rooms that can't be managed,
or can't be used at all by
Googlers in a certain office
or around the world.
So thinking about how the
theories of university days
can--
are put into practice,
I guess, and tested
in many different ways in
the daily developer workflow
has been very--
it's been such a growing
experience for me
as a developer to see
how that plays out.
To think about scale
from the beginning,
to think about the
user from the start.
Yeah.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
That's amazing.
And what about from the product
management side, Lakshmi?
Tell us a little bit more
about what your favorite thing
about being a PM at Google is.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So we say
that PM and Google product
management of Google is
the CEO of their product.
And in it, we truly
believe in that sense.
Like you are a CEO off a
product and all that startup
that you run.
And then you run with your
CTOs and other architects
of the company, which are
all your engineering leaders.
So it's this definition.
I've been a leader in many
companies and various places.
It does not practice
to that extent
and to that scale and impact.
And at least in places
where I have been.
So it's just awesome that you
can just think of an idea,
then you just meet an
engineering leader like meet,
just sitting next to you.
And then say, how about
we work together on this?
Then you go and find a
customer, or you go and find
your open source partners.
And if it works out.
But what works out for me, we
always think like global scale.
So nothing starts
regionally for us.
We always start at
will this affect,
will this problem be solved
for everybody around the world?
And then if it does, we just
go and ask for more people.
We put a business case together.
And sometimes that
idea does not exist.
That product never existed.
It's truly as simple as that.
I've been here 15
months, and there are so
many new things I've done
in all kinds of aspects.
Partnerships, business
temp, you name it.
And then you just
find the right people.
And there are amazing
sort of people.
So it is just rocking
awesome to be--
and I'm not just
doing a sales pitch.
I truly mean it.
So it's really, really
wonderful to be here.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
Incredible opportunities
to make an impact.
I think one of my
favorite stories--
I was asking a Googler,
what's your Google moment?
And he shares with me that he
was a Newgler, a new Googler,
as we call it.
And he is working on this
business critical project.
And it's essentially
when you do a Google
search and the little cards
show up to quickly give you
your snapshot of your answer.
He was working on that, and a
few months after they launched,
the team got a random
email forwarded to them
from a woman in India who noted
that she was able to quickly do
a quick search on
some of her symptoms
that she was having,
quickly diagnosed herself.
Went in and advocated for
herself to get the right care,
and ended up saving both her
life, and she was pregnant,
and her baby's life.
So I think it's just incredible,
these like crazy ways
that we can make just
an impact with something
that feels like it may not.
Do any of you have sort
of a Google moment?
Or something that's
really just helped you
to feel connected to Google
and just love the magic moments
that we have here?
I know.
This one wasn't on the script.
I'm throwing it at
you a little bit.
TARA HERNANDEZ: [INAUDIBLE]
with this one, Kristin.
I have one.
When I was a Newgler,
you spend three days down
in the main campus
learning about Google,
and learning the
tools, and et cetera.
But one of the things I did
not know when I got to Google
was this cool story
out of the Arab Spring,
where you have all of
these activists trying
to advocate and support
democracy in their countries.
And in many cases, you
have these very repressive
governments trying to
shut down the internet
to prevent them from
communicating with each other.
And one of the
things that came out
is that people were spray
painting Google's DNS server
address, which is 8888
on walls of buildings
so that they could keep
their Twitter feeds
going and various
other social media.
And having not known
that, I was like, wow.
OK, I work at a cool company.
That was pretty awesome to me.
And to consider I
had said I'd never
work at Google, because Google
is that stupid company that
makes you calculate how many
golf balls are in a school bus
or something as part of
your interview process.
Which I can assert
they no longer do.
But to be able to be part
of an organization that
has had that much of a
significant positive impact
in the world in such
a meaningful way.
It's kind of hard to
top that in my mind.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I love it.
TARA HERNANDEZ:
Except, I'm sure you're
going to top that, right?
JIMMY MKUDE: No, not quite.
But that is quite hard.
But when I realized
this is where
I was working on a new project.
It's a new API.
We have an ADL implementing it.
And everyone's excited about it.
And we want to launch it.
So I was talking to one of my
senior engineers in a team,
and I'm like, yeah, right now
the servers are pretty good.
They're pretty stable.
I can guarantee you like
99% of the time they're
going to be up.
And he's like, no.
That's not enough.
What do you mean?
99% percent of the
time is not enough?
He's like, yeah.
We need 99.999%
percent of the time.
That 1% can bring down
a lot of-- can affect
a lot of users in one second.
And then he went ahead
and gave it this equation
that I calculated how many
users we have, just our team.
And how much 10
minutes of one server
going down could
affect the ultimate--
that number just blew my mind.
I was like, OK.
Yeah, this is big scale.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Absolutely.
All right.
So we talked a
little bit about what
some of your favorite things
about being a developer
or product manager or
working at Google are.
Let's hear a little bit
more about that real talk,
like peek under the tent.
What are your least
favorite things?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Can I
say the good one first?
KRISTIN COPELAND: Oh, of course.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: OK.
So I'm infrastructure, so I only
talk infrastructure language.
And if you had seen the keynote
this morning, and I saw, to me,
one of the most
powerful thing was
like imagining putting a
firewood under the ocean.
And instead of just,
I've always been
in companies which will do
software innovation, hardware
innovation, [INAUDIBLE],,
all kinds of innovation.
But OK, so we have a very
high latency between Australia
and Singapore.
So how do we fix it?
We did all the wonderful things.
Let's just go to fiber.
And then we reduce the latency.
Oh my God.
Now moments like
that, I think just
you have every single
innovation out there,
and then you do something like
the company of a Google scale
can offer to the world.
I think those are
my aha moments.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Top notch.
Absolutely.
All right.
Back to the real talk.
JIMMY MKUDE: All right, so one
of my least favorite things
actually relates to
my favorite moment,
as well, which is kind of crazy.
But in that same kind
of example that I just
told you guys is, because
Google is such a big company,
sometimes it hinders the speed
that you want to do things at.
So let's say you're
working on a project
and you have everything done.
If you're in a
smaller company, you
could get it out pretty
fast and iterate faster.
But sometimes, because Google
is still a very big company,
they really need to--
everyone needs be confident,
and the quality has to be
the highest quality possible.
So it does take a
little bit longer time,
which as a developer, you
just want to get it done.
I want people to be able to be
helped by what I've just done.
And it just really hurts to have
to wait like another quarter
and just slowly go to the
reviews and everything
until it's ready to launch.
So yeah, that's my kind of--
KRISTIN COPELAND: Yeah.
A lot of trade-offs when
you're worried about scale
and high impact, you
got to also make sure
that it's not adversely
impacting folks.
Which means things can
move a little slower.
I get that.
OK.
Marisa?
MARISA CHOW: Yeah,
I think related
to Jimmy's point about the
scale at which Google has grown.
As Tara mentioned
earlier, Google is not
a very small company anymore.
It is a very large company
across all over the world,
and offices all over the world.
And so my team does
collaborate with teams
that are located in the
different time zones.
And so part of the
frustration with that is,
the company is so
large that sometimes it
can be very difficult to know
what other parts of the company
are doing.
So it's not at
all unusual for me
to first learn of
some Google products
when they show up
in Tech Crunch.
And it's just one of the facts
of being a large company.
But I think that's
something I've actually
taken a bit to heart.
Because I work on
a G Suite product.
I work on meetings.
I work on trying to
make that collaboration,
that connection better.
I work on trying to make
that more seamless, more
frictionless.
And so I think that that
kind of gripe with how large
a company is is something
that fuels me, as well.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I love it.
Tara, anything
you'd like to share?
Should we move on?
All right, all right.
TARA HERNANDEZ: I don't
want to get in trouble.
KRISTIN COPELAND: One
of my favorite thing--
is it cause it's meetings?
You hate meetings the most?
OK.
TARA HERNANDEZ: No comment.
KRISTIN COPELAND: One
of my favorite questions
to ask folks is, when
you're working at Google,
there's so many other companies
that you could choose from.
What brought you to Google?
And what's kept you here?
Tara, take it away.
TARA HERNANDEZ: All right.
I actually, like I
said, I had never
planned on working for Google.
Not just because
of the interview
questions, but just because
I like small companies.
The ability to have
impact at a small company
is just so much, to your
point, is just so much easier.
But I met some amazing women
at meet-ups and cloud events.
And one in particular, a
woman named Melody McFessel.
Another one, Diane
Greene, Alyssa Greene.
There's just all of
these amazing women.
And I was like, wow,
here's a company
that has this sort of fulcrum
of people that I could really
learn from and have an
opportunity to work with.
And I thought, all
right, well, OK.
Maybe I hate big companies,
but this is too good
an opportunity to pass up.
Plus they let me work in
the San Francisco office.
KRISTIN COPELAND: It's
very nice out here.
TARA HERNANDEZ: That
was an added benefit.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I like it.
Jimmy.
JIMMY MKUDE: So for me, if
you don't know my background,
I was born in Tanzania.
So growing up in kind of
a third world country,
it was quite a change
of scenery for me
to come to the United States.
And through my
time in college, I
realized that I wanted
to dedicate my life
to solve real problems
that affect people.
And I didn't really care about
how many users you rack up
for all these different
companies we're talking about.
But at Google, really
what drew me to Google
was the problem they're
trying to solve.
First, they try to
affect the whole world.
So not just the United
States, or the first world.
They try and affect everywhere.
And their problems are
actually affecting people
and enabling people to
do more with their lives,
and enjoy their time more.
So it's problems that
I really cared about.
So that's what
drew me to Google.
And what kept me at
Google, to be honest,
I think it's the food.
The free food is
got to be up there.
Like that is one of
my favorite things.
Every time I think of leaving,
I'm like, oh, but food.
OK, I'm just never mind.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Right.
We're very spoiled.
I'm sure most of you have
heard about the food.
But I can say that it's
one of those things.
I think I saw something like
a meme the other day that
was making fun of Googlers.
Who were talking
about like, I'd rather
work in the San Francisco
office because they have oat
milk instead of almond milk.
And that's a little bit
painting the picture of how
spoiled we can be a little bit.
TARA HERNANDEZ: New
York office has steak.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Oh.
OK, well, I'm moving
to New York, clearly.
Tara, tell me about a little bit
more about what brought you--
sorry-- I'm going to move
on to Lakshmi because you
started that one for us.
Clearly I'm just crushing
it right now, y'all.
Lakshmi, tell me what
brought you to Google
and what's kept you here.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Like almost
everybody said that the--
like the impact, the
scale of the impact
that anybody can make, any
single person can make.
So I'm in networking,
networking infrastructure.
So anything, everything
is connected and secured
through some kind of networking.
All the way from their
device to on prem device,
to a datacenter, to cloud.
And this is a company
which has built it
over years and securely
and phenomenally well.
I think it was a perfect timing,
because we are not number
one yet in cloud game.
So I had huge scope to
kind of participate.
And at the scale that
I was looking at,
there is no other place I
could have thought about where
I could have an impact.
Where there was so
much to do at the scale
that they had already done.
And what is keeping me?
Just that even after
15 months, everyday I
feel like I'm a Newgler.
It is so much to do.
So that's what is
my promise to myself
that I will be able
to make an impact,
and will be able to work
with really smart brains.
Every single day I meet
somebody, I'm like, oh, my God.
Oh, this person wrote the book.
Oh, my God, this
person did this.
So it's just everyday
those moments.
And then learning from
them and being humble,
that's keeping me here.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
That's amazing.
So speaking of the smart people
that you come in contact with.
TARA HERNANDEZ: One more thing.
The thing that
keeps me at Google,
we can bring dogs to the office.
KRISTIN COPELAND: You can what?
TARA HERNANDEZ: Bring
dogs to the office.
The dogs.
Puppies in the
office is literally
one of my favorite
things about Google.
I can't even handle
the cuteness some days.
Two of my co-workers have the
cutest puppies I've ever seen.
I'm so sorry to get
on this tangent,
but yes, dogs in the
office is amazing.
But you did touch
on something that I
want to dig a little deeper on.
The point of working with people
who are just so intelligent.
I'll give you my
quick experience.
So I was leading a meeting,
and one of those meetings
where like I kind of
felt like, I got this.
I'm going to nail this.
I went into the meeting
all strong and confident,
felt like I rocked the meeting.
And then afterwards,
someone was like,
did you know that that guy in
the meeting with you, he like
was a bad ass at Atari.
He was one of those people
that made huge impact, built
all these incredible games.
And you just made
sure that he knew
exactly what he needed to do.
And he's super senior.
And then all of a sudden the
next time I'm meeting with him,
I'm sitting there like,
oh, this guy's so smart.
I'm going to look like
an idiot in front of him.
So it gave me a little
bit of imposter syndrome
of what it's like to work
with these crazy intelligent,
amazing people.
And I'd love to hear
a little bit more
about if you experience
imposter syndrome at Google.
Or how you deal with it.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: I think
this is one of the reasons
that I did not--
Google had been my
customer, partner,
I'd worked with many
times, and vendor.
But I never wanted
to work with Google.
Of the reasons was
that hey, from outside
it looks like when there are
so many smart people, who
each have so many things
in life, the impression
that you feel like, if I
am there, one I'll be lost.
Whether I'll be able
to make an impact.
And second is that, oh, where
do I get the kind of respect
that I get at other the places?
Experience internally
is just like you said.
So I'll give a
very quick example.
As I grew up in India.
I did my Master's in
computer science from India.
And there's a very common
book that lot of Indians
read all the time like
in Master's which is
around computer architecture.
So the person, one of
the authors of that book,
I have been working
with this person
ever since I joined last year.
Just recently another person
who joined my team again,
this person is Indian,
says, oh, Lakshmi.
Isn't he [INAUDIBLE]?
So I said, yeah.
So he said, isn't he the
[INAUDIBLE] who wrote the book?
I'm like, [GASPS] what book?
So then I actually look at him.
I said, David, did
you write that book?
He said, yeah.
And I'm just going
like, oh, my God.
It's been 13 months,
and I'm working
with this person every day.
And I read his book,
and almost every person
at least 18 years back in
India used to read that book.
So that's the kind
of humbleness.
And I can give names and names.
Like person who wrote TCP,
Vint's, like amazing person.
I got to meet that
person with no air.
Everybody here is just here
to solve problems for people.
And that's a common thing
that keeps us all connected.
And that's all we do.
I just get goosebumps, because
I am engineer at heart.
I'm a product manager.
But meeting those people
who are so humble.
And then is just--
it's just amazing
KRISTIN COPELAND: I love it.
Go ahead, Tara.
TARA HERNANDEZ: So I've
actually given talks
on imposter syndrome, and
I suffer from it every day.
And the thing that I
love about at Google
is that so does everybody else.
It's something that
gets talked about a lot.
And you think about, I'm sure
everybody's heard of the Google
20% projects.
And that's pretty widely known.
There was somebody who had a
20% project and invented Gmail.
And it just passed 15 years,
and has like 90 bazillion users.
And you think, oh, my God.
I'm working at a company where
someone just thought of that
as a side project.
That's very intimidating.
But at the same time,
to Lakshmi's point,
there's a lot of
motivation around.
We all have the
capability and opportunity
to really do
something meaningful
for us and for the company.
And more to Jimmy's point,
to the world at large.
It's not often that you get
to work at a company that
could have global impact.
And so there's a sense
of responsibility
that I think a lot of
us carry that maybe it's
not the official motto, but
every employee is, do good,
don't be evil.
Don't take it for granted
All of those things
that for us as Googlers in
the trenches working along,
it's like we think
about it all the time.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Yeah.
Love it.
TARA HERNANDEZ: So
intent in some ways,
and a sense of sort
of technical ethics,
and other types of
things are things
that are just as
important as what
type of crazy
technical innovation
is going to make
us a lot of money.
That's not really what
we care about as much.
At least with all of the
people that I have met,
that's not the case.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Absolutely.
I'd love to hear a little
bit more about skills
that you've developed at Google.
Because I know I
personally have seen
some of these different courses
we have available to us,
and have benefited from them.
I recently took a finance
course which is amazing,
because let's be real, I know
nothing about how to invest.
So I'd love to hear.
What's a skill that you've
developed here at Google?
Whether or not it's related
to your core job, or something
that you've learned via
courses that we offer.
Share.
MARISA CHOW: So I'll list two.
One technical skill and then
one non-technical skill.
Technical skill is, so my team
works on video conferencing,
as I mentioned.
And a large part of
that is reliability,
so making sure that our
rooms are reliably working
at any given point in time.
So a huge part of
my job is looking
at rooms that are broken, trying
to diagnose why something is--
why a room is
suddenly went offline.
And there is just so many
dimensions to that problem.
Is it a problem in the software?
Is there a problem
in the hardware?
in the building?
There are layers and layers of
where the problem could happen.
So I would say one
skill that I've
developed is learning
to look at a symptom
and try to think about
what are the causes that
could affect that, that
could make that happen?
Where along the chain
could something go wrong?
The non-technical
skill is really fun.
I took an ASL class
at the office.
They offer ASL classes.
And it was something I'd
always wanted to learn,
and didn't really have
a chance to learn.
So when they offered the
class, I just jumped at it.
And it was a lot of fun.
I really enjoyed it.
KRISTIN COPELAND: That's great.
Anyone else?
JIMMY MKUDE: So the
skill that I learned,
actually it's weird because
I thought I was the master
of C++.
I was like there's nothing
I can learn more about C++.
TARA HERNANDEZ: [INAUDIBLE]
JIMMY MKUDE: That's
what I learned.
So at Google we have
this thing where
after you join the
company, you can
go through readability reviews.
And you have people who are very
knowledgeable in the language
review your code and give
you pointers to what you do.
And my first readability
approval review,
that was the most exciting
moment I ever had.
Because I learned so
much in that one review,
than let's say, a
year in college.
Because gave me pointers
and reasons and why--
like you give the
whole rationale.
Do it like this because of ABC.
And you think about
it, you're like, yes.
Why didn't I think
of that before?
And you go back and it's--
every time I have those
reviews, it' just amazing.
And these people
work in the company,
and you can just ping
them and be like,
do you want to have lunch?
And they'll be like, yeah.
Let's get lunch.
We have steak over here.
So you go and talk to them.
And you learn so--
I am a C++ nerd so I enjoy
having lunch with these people.
And the more I learned,
the more happy I am.
So I don't think I'm ever
going to be a master at C++.
That's what I learned, as well.
Be humble.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I love it.
I love it.
So in our last minute or
so, we'll end on a fun note.
I'd love for each of you-- one
of you mentioned the great food
at Google.
I'd love to hear
from each of you
what the best thing
you've eaten at Google is.
The best food you've
eaten at Google.
Yeah.
All right so mine is--
JIMMY MKUDE: It's got
to be Japan office.
In Tokyo, they had--
I don't know what the name of
the food is, but it was just,
it's different from
here because you
have sort of just one meal
is little meals everywhere.
And you just pick
and choose and eat.
And I remember eating, the
first time I was there,
I ate so much that I got sick.
But it was so good.
KRISTIN COPELAND: I love it.
JIMMY MKUDE: It
was so different.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Like a
Japanese version of tapas?
OK.
Yeah, I can get on
board with that.
Lakshmi, what about you?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So I'm
vegetarian, no egg,
and no meat, no seafood.
So one thing which I really
love is that the food here
is super healthy.
And I do like healthy food.
So you have all
kinds of options,
but out of all the
offices I've travelled,
Google at Singapore office, they
have like a seven star buffet.
And the view is
so super awesome,
so that's my favorite
place for vegetarian food.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Awesome.
All right, Tara.
What about you?
TARA HERNANDEZ:
Chocolate chip cookies
at the San Francisco office.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Yes,
those are amazing.
TARA HERNANDEZ: They
have sea salt, and--
MARISA CHOW: I feel like
my answer to this changes
every week.
But yes, so in the
New York office
they have this one cafe where
they will plate everything very
nicely on like a huge plate.
So you see this
beautiful white plate,
and it'll have like a
perfect I don't know--
I'm blanking.
Like for example, like some
sort of really fancy pasta
with a pumpkin sauce on
it with a beautiful sprig
of green something.
Yeah, gold leaves or something.
It's just so beautiful.
And you know, as a
millennial, I have
to say it's very Instagrammable.
It's very aesthetic.
It's beautiful.
KRISTIN COPELAND: If
it's IG worthy, I mean--
JIMMY MKUDE: They
also have hidden bars.
KRISTIN COPELAND: Yes, yes.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: And
peanut butter sandwiches.
They just started it
recently in Sunnyvale office.
I love them.
KRISTIN COPELAND:
A simple staple.
Who doesn't love that?
Fantastic.
All right.
Well, that wraps
up our panel today.
So let's give it up for
these amazing panelists.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all so much.
We hope you enjoyed
learning a little bit more
about what it's like in
the life of a Googler.
[MUSIC PLAYING]